.
>> HEY, TUCKER.
>> IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE SPAN
BETWEEN TRAGEDY COMING ACROSS
THE iPHONE AND PARTISAN
RESPONSES GETTING DOWN TO THE
NEAREST SECOND.
>> IT IS THE SECOND TIME AND I
THINK SEVEN DAYS THAT I HAVE
BEEN ON YOUR SHOW WHERE BOTH OF
WHICH HAVE HAD INCREDIBLY
HEINOUS AND HORRIFIC TRAGEDIES
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWED BY NAKED
EXPLOITATION OF THE DEAD BODIES
BEFORE ANYTHING IS KNOWN ABOUT
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED INCLUDING
THE KILLER.
I WAS WATCHING JOE BIDEN AND I
EMPATHIZE SO MUCH WITH WHAT WILL
SAID THAT AT THE BEGINNING OF
HIS SPEECH I WAS REALLY HOPING
THAT HE WOULD STRIKE EXACTLY THE
NOTE OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS TWICE
HAD TO BURY A CHILD AND COULD
REALLY EMPATHIZE WITH A UNIQUE
WAY WITH HOW UNIQUELY HEINOUS IT
IS, AND COULD TALK ABOUT THE
SPIRITUALITY OF OUR SOCIETY AND
THE NEED TO UNITE ON WHAT
OBVIOUSLY, EVERYONE NO MATTER
WHAT YOUR PARTISAN PERSPECTIVE
IS, REACTING THE SAME WAY WHEN
SEEING THIS THING AND SPENT
ABOUT SIX SECONDS DOING THAT AND
THEN IMMEDIATELY DID A DETOUR TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HE COULD SQUEEZE
AND EXPLOIT THE SITUATION FOR
PARTISAN ADVANTAGE.
IT WAS SO GROTESQUE AND I MEAN,
UNSURPRISING, BUT ALSO REALLY
DISAPPOINTING TO WATCH.
>> Tucker: AND AS GOD WATCHES,
I WOULD'VE PRAISED JOE BIDEN IF
HE KEPT TO THE FIRST PART OF
THAT SPEECH, LOSING TWO CHILDREN
AND NOT MANY PEOPLE CAN SAY THAT
AND KNOWS WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
I WOULD LISTEN CAREFULLY TO HIM
AND I WOULD FEEL GREAT DEEPLY
GRATEFUL IF YOU USE THIS MOMENT
TO UNITE THE COUNTRY, WE ALL ARE
UNITED IN OUR GRIEF AS WE WATCH
CHILDREN DIE, WHY NOT DO THAT?
>> I THINK THE OBSESSION OF
PEOPLE DOING POLITICS FULL-TIME
SEEING THE WORLD THROUGH THIS
PARTISAN OF PRISM WARFARE IS
CONSUMING THAT IT BASICALLY
DRAINS THEIR ENTIRE SOUL SO THAT
NOTHING IS LEFT BUT THIS KIND OF
IMMEDIATE NEED TO USE EVERY
SITUATION NO MATTER HOW TRAGIC
TO GAIN SOME KIND OF AN
ADVANTAGE.
AND JOE BIDEN IS A POLITICIAN,
HE IS IN PUBLIC POLICY, THERE
ARE A PUBLIC POLICY ASPECTS FOR
THINGS LIKE THIS, SO IF YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THAT, THAT IS
FINE, BUT WAIT A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME, NOT JUST FOR THE EMOTIONS
TO BE PROCESSED, BUT BASIC FACTS
ARE KNOWN ABOUT WHO THIS PERSON
IS, WHAT MOTIVATED THEM, WHAT
ROLE GUNS HAD IN TERMS OF GUN
CONTROL OR ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT, THEY DON'T
WAIT AT ALL BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
EXPLOIT THOSE EMOTIONS THAT THEY
COULD BE USING TO UNITE PEOPLE
AND INSTEAD TO WORK THEM TO
THEIR OWN ADVANTAGE.
IT IS SO GHOULISH AND GROTESQUE
TO WATCH.
>> Tucker: IT REALLY IS,
PEOPLE HAVE DIED AND WE OWE THEM
THE RESPECT OF RESTRAINT.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT ALL
DEATH.
I KNOW THAT YOU AGREE